die Geschichte ist ihr habt die Umfrage
gewonnen auf Facebook
also die meisten Fans haben für euch
gestimmt wer soll das nächste Interview
bei klickum kriegen es wird jetzt nicht
das nächste Interview aber bei uns
gibt's ja immer die nutzerfragen und
jetzt geht es darum dass man euch
nutzerfrage stellen kann aber ich frage
mich immer noch warum haben habt ihr
diese Umfrage ihr seid habt K1 überholt
wie kommt das ich weiß nicht musst du
die Fans fragen jetztum wir den überholt
haben ich habe jetzt nicht drauf
geachtet vorstellen warum wir den ersten
Preis belegt haben oder wie man das
nennen mag weil die Interviews mit uns
immer sehr unterhaltsam sind also es
wird nie langweilig oder sonstiges kein
0815 es gibt immer was Neues zum lachen
wir haben immer irgendwelche neuen
flashen du weißt Bruder brud immer was
Neues und das gefällt den Zuschauern die
können nicht davon genug bekommen und es
errt uns definitiv sehr dass wir auf
jeden Fall gewonnen haben jetzt machen
wir erstmal zwar nicht nur das Interview
mit dem wird witzig sondern hoffentlich
auch auch eure Nutzer Fragen das heißt
ihr habt jetzt die Möglichkeit seid
fleißig kreativ lest den Infotext und am
besten als videofrage und dann dann
kommt ihr vielleicht dran wenn ihr
besonders originell seid was ist eure
lieblingsfrage oder welche Frage wollt
ihr nicht mehr hören W habt euch
kennengelernt die fragt uns jeder fragt
uns echt jeder okay wo habt ihr euch
eigentlich nee das vergessen wir jetzt
also bis dann bleibt dran Moment Moment
eins hab wir noch das Interview kommt
nämlich nicht sofort hier haben wir ein
paar asls die können sagen wann kommt
das Interview im Juni genau weil dann
kommt das Album auch von Cello und Abdi
raus und bis dahin genau ihr die hab
ordentlich gevotet deswegen haben sie
gewonnen aber nicht vergessen bis dahin
ein paar Haftbefehl Videos gucken die
wir jetzt hier unten von heute verlink
also haut
rein